e
de son histoire.
Déjà, plus de 4 millions de
volailles des villages ont été
abattus au pays.
70 millions d'oiseaux ont été
tués au total, dans 50 pays.
France Beaudoin.
Olivier Bourque, Ottawa veut
- En octobre dernier,
la productrice de dindons
Marie-Christine parents a dû
faire abattre 11 500 oiseaux
à cause de la grippe aviaire.
MARIE-CHRISTINE PARENT,
copropr., Ferme Dindons du Roy
- Tu ne souhaites pas ça
à ton pire ennemi, là,
des aventures comme ça.
- Pour éviter le retour du
virus, la ucucuctrice a nettoyé
ses poulaillers et a fait
remplacer les planchers.
- Tant que les planchers ne sont
pas changés, je ne peux pas
avoir l'approbation du nettoyage
complété, ce qui m'empêche
asasasser à l'étape
de désinfection.
- La production devrait donc
reprendre en janvier prochain.
Près de chez elle,
un producteur a fait euthanasier
45 000 poulets et 30 000 poules
pondeuses. Et tout récemment,
en Colombie-Britannique,
14 fermes ont été infectées
en une semaine. À l'Agence
canadienne d'inspection des
aliments, la coordination des
mesures d'urgence est complexe.
MANON RACICOT, Agence canadienne
d'inspection des aliments
- On est dans une situation
où le virus est exceptionnel,
on n'a jamais vu ça avant.
- Depuis un an, un nombre sans
précédent d'oiseaux d'élevage
est abattu :
50 millions aux États-Unis,
20 millions en France.
En Vendée, d'immenses fosses
temporaires ont été creusées
par les autorités sanitaires
pour enfouir les carcasses.
Les centres d'équarrissage
étant complètement débordés, des
producteurs doivent euthanasier
eux-mêmes leurililililles.
CHRISTIAN DROUIN, producteur de
poulets certifiés
- On nous a dit, un peu
en off : "Vous fermez la
ventilation de votre bâtiment,
toute une nuit et aprè
vous ramassez les cadavres
dans les jours qui suivent."
- Et comme au Canada,
de nouveaux foyers d'éclosion
apparaissent depuis l'automne,
en France. Les éleveurs ne sont
pas au bout de leur peine,
selon alalalalaliste
des maladies aviaires.
JEAN-PIERRE VAILLANCOURT,
professeur titulaire, UdM
- Ça devrait diminuer
avec l'arrivée de l'hiver.
s s s s s au printemps prochain,
bien, on est à très haut risque
que ça reprenne.
- Éleveurs et scientifiques
cherchent un remède efficace.
La vaccination est envisagée
Les grands pays exportateurs
de volailles l'interdisent, mais
l'ampleur de la tututututuelle
change la donne et des projets
pilotes de vaccination sont
en cours en Europe. Ici France ,
Radio-Canada, Québe